oh hi how are you today
good you find anything alright 5853
is your total without the balance
rewards thank you
so if you have a chip card you go ahead
put the chip into the bottom of the PIN
pad cutting I'm not going to be home
tonight
yeah chip card
sure these new chip card readers might
be more secure but being shackled to a
credit card reader and unsure of what to
do it's maddening the u.s. is in the
middle of a major payment technology
transition and it certainly isn't as
smooth as a swipe I timed dozens of
transactions on average chip cards took
13 seconds swiping 6 seconds from start
of the swipe to completed transaction
and you get to put your card away while
you wait don't worry help is on the way
but before we get to that you need to
understand why these chip cards are a
very good thing during a transaction the
magnetic strips on traditional cards
send static unchanging data to the
financial institutions to confirm the
card and account if a credit card hacker
access the sensitive data it could be
used to make fraudulent purchases over
and over again with chip cards or EMV
cards the small computer chip is used to
create a unique transaction code that is
sent to the financial institutions if a
hacker accessed the data from one
specific point of sale it would never
work again but what if I told you you
could have the same EMV security benefit
with twice the speed the answers in here
Apple pay Samsung pay and Android pay
we're all twice as fast as chip credit
cards in my testing hold up your phone
press on the fingerprint sensor and
confirm it's you and that's it plus it
stores like Walgreens you don't have to
put in your phone number to get loyalty
points here's the best part about the
chip card revolution many of the new
terminals put into stores to support the
new cards can support mobile payments
they just need to be enabled with
software updates in the meantime there's
hope on the way for those plastic cards
the major banks and credit card
companies are working to roll out quick
chip options so you can pull out your
card after just two seconds then put it
away just this week a store in Santa
Cruz began rolling out the faster chip
payment system yes it's one big waiting
game
my advice
your phone to be your credit card right
now I'm sorry were you speaking to me oh
you can go ahead and remove your card